merci Daniel Boyer de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élu du
Val-de-Marne donc du groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire on va bien sûr
commencer par la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui a donc rejeté pour
la deuxième fois la demande de
référendum qui avait été déposée par les
sénateurs de gauche qu'elle a été votre
sentiment de la déception
c'était attendu mais en fait ça provoque
une interrogation sur les portes de
sortie de la crise démocratique que l'on
vise clairement le retour devant les
citoyens était une porte qui aurait été
honorable et par ailleurs qui auraient
sans doute renforcé une démocratie un
peu à bout de souffle ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que ce RIP a peut-être
été fait pour ne jamais pouvoir être
utilisé et que la Cinquième République a
besoin d'être rénové et d'avoir quelques
conquêtes démocratiques qui viennent
revivifier une démocratie à bout de
souffle où les pouvoirs sont excessifs
pour l'exécutif et le président de la
République vous souhaitez changer les
modalités d'application de ce rythme et
un sénateur socialiste qui va déposer
une proposition de loi à ce sujet c'est
une bonne chose pour nous mais bien sûr
quand il y avait eu l'affaire de la
privatisation d'ADP on avait vu la
difficulté qu'il y a à mobilisé sur un
sujet qui ne parieur ne concernait pas
tous les Français là je suis à peu près
certain que nous aurions obtenu les
millions de signatures indispensables
pour
sur cette consultation moi je crois
surtout si vous voulez qu'en fait la
question est moins RIP ou Paris c'est
comment cette réforme qui est rejetée
qui est injuste peut-être aujourd'hui
remise en cause des manifestations
ininterrompues une mobilisation UNE
intercendicale UNIE un parlement qui ne
vote pas cette loi un RIP projeté et
après et après la crise qui continue
donc nous nous allons continuer à nous
battre car cette réforme est
profondément injuste en prenant deux ans
de la vie de nos concitoyens mais
comment est-ce que vous pouvez encore la
remettre en cause cette réforme où
est-ce que vous êtes résigné au fait
qu'elle va rentrer en vigueur absolument
pas on a eu l'exemple avec le CPE du
fait que nous d'ailleurs nous avons
combattre sur tous les fronts il y a la
proposition de loi de l'IoT qui qui
permettra à nouveau un débat et puis ça
permettra que les députés se prononcent
explicitement sur le sujet ce qui n'a
pas été
je ne sais pas parce que je crois que
chez nos collègues les républicains il
doit y avoir beaucoup de serrage de
boulons en ce moment vous poserez la
question à Bruno retaille au même si
c'est pas son groupe c'est sa famille
politique donc je ne suis pas certain
qu'elle puisse être voté mais en tous
les cas elle montrera aussi et elle
permettra que chaque député s'exprime
sur cette question du report de l'âge à
64 ans et ça je pense c'est une bonne
chose parce que les députés doivent
rendre compte devant leurs électeurs de
leur choix politique et c'est la moindre
des choses qu'ils aient à s'exprimer
formellement ce sera l'avantage de cette
réforme puis on contestera les décrets
d'application les syndicats ont
programmé une autre un autre mouvement
de protestation vous savez peut-être la
réforme finira par s'appliquer puisque
le gouvernement a l'air déterminé mais
si elle s'applique ce sera peut-être
encore pire pour notre pays hier on
votait le enfin on débattait du pack de
stabilité
8 milliards en 2027 c'est ce que
produira l'effet de cette réforme des
retraites c'est exactement ce qu'on a
consacré à l'Ariston de 30 centimes sur
le lit de naissance en 2022 franchement
regardez les enjeux regarder le
bouleversement de la vie de notre pays
est-ce que vraiment ça valait le coup
non ça ne vaut pas le coup et cette
réforme doit être remise au placard
un mot sur ce qui s'est passé le 1er mai
et c'est violent ça qui ont eu lieu dans
les cortèges de nombreuses villes de
France est-ce que pour vous il faut une
nouvelle loi pour lutter contre les
plaques blocs moi je pense qu'on a deux
sujets le premier sujet je veux redire
je suis écologiste donc les violences ne
font pas partie de notre pensée de notre
arsenal on est au contraire par principe
contre ces violences et j'ai une pensée
je le dis aussi pour ce fonctionnaire
qui a reçu un cocktail Molotov dont on
voit les images mais donc j'ai une
pensée aussi pour les manifestants
blessés parce que dans chacune des
manifestations il y a eu des
manifestants blessés la première chose
c'est que les manifestations se
déroulent bien dans l'immense majorité
des cas j'ai participé à toute en
rejoignant parfois le Sénat parce que
nous avions des des débats donc tout ça
se déroule très bien ensuite on a un
problème en France de doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre dans tous les pays
il y a une logique de désescalade
d'éloignement des forces de police
comme on dit mais moi j'hésite à les
manifester et le 1er mai il y avait
souvent des manifestations en famille et
aujourd'hui vous voyez beaucoup moins de
familles avec enfants dans les
manifestations parce que les gens ont
peur et ça diminue cette mobilisation
donc il faut d'abord réexpliquer que le
droit de manifester fondamental et qu'au
fond les Black Blocs sont un peu quand
même les idiots utiles du gouvernement
parce que il décourage ses
manifestations ensuite bon moi je suis
pas un expert du du maintien de l'ordre
je pense qu'il appartient au
gouvernement de trouver les dispositifs
mais quand vous avez des des dispositifs
comme la Bravet etc franchement je je
pense que le ministre de l'Intérieur a
tort de ne pas s'interroger sur le
dispositif de maintien de l'ordre et de
ne pas regarder ce qui se fait dans les
autres pays européens où il y a aussi
des contestations sociales et il y a
rarement le niveau de violence qui est
atteint dans notre pays
en tous les cas je pense que cette
modalité d'intervention ne me paraît pas
ne me paraît pas tout à fait conforme à
ce que j'évoque avec la nécessité plutôt
d'une politique de désescalade que d'une
politique d'espérée il y a des casseurs
qui viennent pour tuer du flic est-ce
que pour vous changer la stratégie de
maintien de l'ordre ça résoudrait le
problème moi écoutez je constate
pour tuer du flic pour tuer du flic que
j'espère que non je suis je suis quand
même pas certain enfin j'espère vraiment
que que non mais il y a des gens qui
viennent pour casser ça c'est certain il
s'attaque souvent d'ailleurs à des
symboles des banques des donc on le voit
bien mais pour moi si vous voulez les
dégradations matérielles sont une chose
les atteintes aux personnes sont sont
autre chose et puis dans les manifs il y
a des gens qui se retrouvent enfermés
qui se retrouvent aussi sous les gaz
lacrymogènes les fonctionnaires
polissent eux-mêmes sont exposés si vous
voulez donc franchement je pense qu'il
faut s'interroger peut-être que
d'ailleurs je suis je suis toujours
assez surpris parce que les Black Blocs
c'est combien de personnes c'est des
personnes on arrive à identifier le
hooligans on n'arrive pas à identifier
les les Black Box honnêtement je suis je
suis toujours très interrogatif sur le
fait quand je suis arrivé à la
manifestation
on m'a fouillé par exemple on m'a
demandé de présenter mon sac à dos de
manifestations
en tous les cas je pense qu'il faut des
dispositifs qui garantissent
effectivement le droit de de manifester
et si on peut empêcher les Black Blocs
de manifester des gens qui viennent qui
jettent des cocktails Molotov
effectivement ils méritent d'avoir une
interdiction de manifester de la loi
pour que les Black Blocs ne puissent
plus à agir comme une
demandeur d'un débat sur la technique de
maintien de l'ordre qui à mon avis leur
donne la part belle et renforce le
risque de ces tensions on va parler de
la suite je le disais le gouvernement
qui cherche à tourner la page de la
réforme des retraites et veut passer à
l'étape d'après notamment sur la
question de l'emploi et du travail sujet
que vous suivez particulièrement Daniel
Brier Elizabeth borne a présenté des
mesures dans sa feuille de route des 100
jours on regarde le détail avec Audrey
Vitaa
[Musique]
bonjour
et Audrey parmi les chantiers lancés par
l'exécutif il y a donc la question du
travail toutes ces formes et la première
ministre a donc détaillé dans sa
première feuille de route vous allez
tout nous expliquer Audrey nous éclair
déjà nous nous éclairer sur le
calendrier en tout cas je vais essayer
parce que tout n'est pas encore précisé
parmi les textes qui devraient arriver
vite dans les trois mois il y a le
projet de loi sur le partage de la
valeur ajoutée un terme un texte pardon
plutôt consensuel puisque le sujet est
porté par une majorité de syndicats
écouter la première administration
c'est un texte important
jusqu'ici seuls les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés avaient l'obligation de
proposer un dispositif de partage de la
valeur à leur salarié cet accord
permettra de toucher toutes les PME en
abaissant le seuil de 50 à 11 salariés
pour une durée de 5 ans au moins
par ailleurs les entreprises de plus de
50 salariés qui font des résultats
exceptionnels auront l'obligation de
négocier la mise en place d'un
dispositif de partage de la valeur
un texte que les syndicats appellent de
leurs vœux donc peut-être une manière de
rouvrir le dialogue après la réforme des
retraites peut-être mais les
négociations s'annoncent apres sur tout
ce qui touchera à la thématique du
travail écoutez Laurent Berger le
secrétaire général de la CFDT il était
dans le cortège du premier mai je pense
qu'on a un gouvernement qui est
déconnecté qui pense que tout ça est
derrière nous non c'est pas derrière
nous aujourd'hui il y a un monde du
travail ou la colère est assez présente
ou le ressentiment est très présent et
qui demande des réponses évidemment sur
le sujet des retraites mais qui demande
des réponses sur la question salariale
sur la question des conditions de
travail et la CFDT et l'IRA discuter
mais il ira discuter en considérant tout
coûte plus cher et qui va avoir
maintenant sur les conditions de travail
comme sur la question salariale comme
sur la question du dialogue social que
des choses toi mis sur la table qui soit
consistante si c'est le cas on discutera
si pas le cas je crois que le
gouvernement n'aura encore pas compris
Daniel Boyer vous y croyez vous un
retour à la table de négociation et à
des discussions qui reprennent d'abord
je voudrais faire une remarque on a
débattu de la réforme des retraites dans
un projet de loi de finance rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale et on a été
empêché de débattre de tous ces sujets
de conditions de travail de partage de
la valeur par le cadre même qui avait
choisi de gouvernement et aujourd'hui il
court derrière pour revenir mettre en
débat ce qui était indispensable parce
que on ne peut pas parler de l'âge de
départ de en retraite sans parler des
conditions de travail pourquoi les
citoyens protestent parce que beaucoup
sont épuisés au moment où ils arrivent à
la retraite et ils ont envie d'avoir une
autre vie que celle-là donc bien sûr
qu'il faut débattre de ces questions de
travail de partage de la valeur dans les
années 80 monsieur Calvet gagnait 40
fois le salaire d'un de ses employés
aujourd'hui chez ces lentis le rapport
entre le salaire du patron et le salaire
moyen de ses employés c'est 1100 fois
le patron de stellantis gagne en trois
heures 37 minutes le salaire moyen
annuel d'un de ses salariés c'est ça
n'est pas possible si on veut une
société qui se tient où il y a de la
cohésion sociale ça n'est pas possible
qu'il y ait tant d'accumulation de
richesse chez quelques-uns et tant de
difficultés à vivre chez La Grand la
plus grande partie de nos concitoyens
donc bien sûr il faut que ces sujets
soient évoqués mais ils sont premiers et
ça n'est pas en demandant deux ans de
travail en plus qu'on doit équilibrer
des comptes c'est en répartissant au
contraire différemment la richesse
produite dans notre pays évidemment
bénéfice des salariés et Audrey il y a
d'autres choses à l'agenda sur ces
questions travaillées d'emploi oui
plusieurs textes finalement dans le
courant du mois de juin il y a la
transformation de Pôle emploi en France
travail la gouvernance sera partagée
entre l'État les collectivités les
partenaires sociaux l'objectif c'est de
simplifier les démarches mais aussi
d'inciter à la reprise d'activités
notamment pour les personnes au RSA on
va en parler pour le reste c'est un peu
plus flou de très nombreux sujets sont
sur la table après justement la réforme
des retraites le gouvernement espère au
moins dresser un calendrier d'ici
juillet avec les partenaires sociaux
avec des négociations qui dureront au
moins jusqu'à la fin de l'année et si
tout va bien un projet de loi travail en
2024 et vous allez voir on va écouter
une nouvelle fois la première ministre
il y a pléthore de sujets
perspective de carrière et reconversion
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
emploie des seniors compte épargne tant
universel suite de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage tous les sujets sont
sur la table avec les partenaires
sociaux pour améliorer la vie au travail
réforme de l'assurance chômage et puis
je les dis plus haut réforme du RSA
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le bon
timing le bon moment après la référence
à la droite au fond monsieur Macron
reprend les vieilles anciennes avec le
fait de demander des heures de travail
ou de formation personne au RSA quand
vous êtes au RSA seul vous gagnez 607
euros par mois quand vous avez trois
enfants vous gagnez 1500 donc on
continue à croire que ces gens sont des
profiteurs il y a 30% des gens qui
pourraient bénéficier du RSA qui ne font
pas valoir leur droit au RSA et personne
n'est heureux de vivre au RSA donc aider
des personnes au RSA à retrouver de
l'emploi ça c'est effectivement un volet
très important
mais les contraindre et au fond les
culpabiliser dire vous voyez ils ne
veulent pas travailler c'est pour ça il
faut donc les leur imposer quelque chose
c'est vraiment une dérive gouvernement
le gouvernement dit c'est un
accompagnement vers l'emploi oui mais on
déguise un accompagnement vers l'emploi
en imposant un temps de 15 à 20h
d'ailleurs la Seine-Saint-Denis le
patron de la Seine-Saint-Denis enfin le
président de la Seine-Saint-Denis
Stéphane Troussel a décidé de se retirer
de cette expérimentation au vu de son
contenu et il a raison moi je me
rappelle avoir connu dans dans ma vie de
mère des personnes au RSA qui était
malmené par les services fiscaux parce
qu'ils étaient bénévoles dans des
associations on leur reprochait alors
que c'est une activité très utile pour
maintenir les gens en insertion que
d'avoir une activité bénévole on le
reprochait de ne pas finalement
consacrer tous leurs temps à la
recherche d'emploi et maintenant on va
leur demander de faire 15 heures 20
heures de quoi si c'est des heures de
formation c'est très bien il faut
développer les possibilités d'accès à
l'emploi mais au fond c'est de
culpabilisation on dit que les gens qui
ne travaillent pas sont responsables du
non travail et on propose comme travail
des des jobs sous-payés
ubérisaient etc qui effectivement ne
font pas envie et qui fait que on a
beaucoup d'emplois qui ne trouvent pas
d'ailleurs à être pourvu aujourd'hui
donc pas de culpabilisation des gens au
RSA c'est un droit fondamental comme le
droit aux allocations chômage comme le
droit à la retraite et finalement on
touche au droit qui protège les plus
faibles de nos concitoyens les uns après
les autres parmi les thèmes dont on ne
reparle plus vraiment il y a ce qui a
été retoqué par le Conseil
constitutionnel je pense à l'index
senior ou au CDI seniors ça pourrait
apparaître dans un texte sur l'emploi
des seigneurs justement vous vous
appelez de vos vœux à ce qu'on remette
ces sujets sur la table où il faut les
oublier l'index seniors on l'oublie
moi j'appelle surtout de mon vœu que on
retire la réforme l'âge de 64 ans et ce
qui permettra de de s'intéresser
collectivement à la façon dont déjà les
vous savez la moitié des des plus de 60
ans sont déjà en cessation d'activité
avant de pouvoir accéder à leur droit à
la retraite donc
cette question de l'index senior ou de
l'emploi des seniors est une question
qui mérite vous évoquez le compte
épargne tant par exemple c'est un sujet
que la CFDT portait en disant ça
pourrait permettre aussi d'avoir un
accompagnement les dernières années avec
un emploi à mi-temps enfin une
transition vers la retraite qui soit une
transition douce au regard des
souffrances au travail des difficultés
pour un certain nombre de salariés donc
tous ces sujets méritent d'être débattus
ils auraient même mérité d'être débattus
dans le cadre d'une loi cohérente d'une
loi travail et pas d'une loi de
rectification de des finances de la
sécurité sociale pour juste faire passer
cette pilule des 64 ans donc je ne sais
pas ce que décideront les les syndicats
mais je crois que ils ont raison de dire
la facture il faudra de vrais débat et
j'ai un doute là-dessus parce qu'en fait
au fond le gouvernement vient toujours
avec ces solutions clés en main à
prendre ou à l'essai donc la négociation
ça n'est pas ça c'est d'écouter des
partenaires et je pense que les
partenaires sociaux rediront que les
mesures d'âge ne sont pas des bonnes
mesures pour la retraite et que pour
réouvrir le débat bah ouvrons le
vraiment sur les conditions de travail
et sur le fait pourquoi des gens n'en
peuvent plus à 60 ans dans leur travail
on me dit mais vous ne soutenez pas le
travail vive la valeur travail etc mais
si les gens sont usés c'est aussi parce
que le travail
use donc il ne faut pas seulement
prendre des mesures individuelles sur
les personnes il faut prendre des
mesures de transformation des conditions
même de travail et tout ça bah moi je
fais confiance aux syndicats pour porter
ça je fais beaucoup moins confiance au
gouvernement pour être dans une réelle
concertation qui est indispensable sur
tous ces sujets
on va voir l'actualité dans votre
département maintenant on va aller dans
le Val-de-Marne on retrouve Cécile
Dubois bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous rédactrice en chef à 94
citoyens Cécile vous allez nous parler
de la question de l'eau
oui bonjour Merci de votre invitation
bonjour oui je vais vous parler de l'eau
potable en Île-de-France le Syndicat des
Eaux d'Île-de-France qui gère l'eau
potable d'un tiers des habitants de la
région souhaite mettre en place un
nouveau mode de traitement de l'eau qui
inclut une nouvelle étape de filtration
membranaire dites osmose inverse basse
pression qui promet une filtration de
100000 à 1 million de fois plus petite
qu'un cheveu pour ne laisser passer que
les molécules d'eau alors c'est un petit
peu technique mais la promesse c'est
d'avoir une eau plus pure avec quasiment
plus de traces de pesticides plus de
traces de polluants éternel comme les
pfas et à terme plus de chlore donc un
meilleur goût et donc en termes
d'intérêt écologique le CDI fait valoir
une plus grande durée de vie des
produits qui utilisent de l'eau car elle
sera moins calcaire une diminution de
l'achat de bouteilles d'eau et aussi une
diminution puis une suppression du
chlore donc actuellement une
concertation publique se tient
jusqu'au mois de juillet et tous les
citoyens sont invités à donner leur avis
j'aurais aimé savoir quel était votre
position en tant que sénateur par
rapport à ce à ce débat à cette question
quel est votre position comment
comptez-vous prendre par au débat voir
élargir ce débat à la gouvernance de
l'eau potable comme dit invité la
présidente par intérim de la Commission
du débat Commission nationale du débat
public il a rien Casio
c'est une technique très coûteuse s'il
s'est dit doit mettre en place cet outil
dans l'ensemble de ces de ces
usines c'est à peu près 2 milliards
d'euros et 20 centimes de plus sur la
facture d'eau des consommateurs et on
produit une tellement pure qu'il faut
rajouter de l'eau à la sortie pour
qu'elle puisse être potable
c'est par ailleurs une technique très
coûteuse aussi en énergie donc moi je
suis écologiste je pense d'abord aux
logiques de sobriété et très franchement
je m'interroge et je me demande même si
ça n'est pas au fond une façon de rendre
notre dépendance à Veolia quasiment
définitive parce que ces techniques ne
sont accessibles qu'à des très grands
groupes comme les le groupe Veolia qui
depuis plus de 100 ans quand même
détient le marché de l'eau de
l'essentiel des des habitants
d'Île-de-France vous le savez il y a eu
des retours en régie ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs de la commune dont j'ai été
élu et beaucoup de communes du du de
l'ancien Val de Bièvre bon moi je
je n'exclut pas totalement et d'ailleurs
je regarderai attentivement et
j'essaierai de participer à ces débats
parce qu'il y a une situation qui est
nouvelle c'est que plus on cherche les
polluants plus on en trouve on a trouvé
encore plus de la moitié de l'eau
distribuée en France contient des
polluants les phases que vous avez
évoquées évidemment des herbicides des
des pesticides ça n'empêche d'ailleurs
pas notre ministre de l'Agriculture de
dire qu'il faut continuer à aller
utiliser tant qu'on a pas de solution et
du coup en fait nous notre logique est
plutôt de dire évitons les pollutions de
l'eau plutôt que de mettre en place des
systèmes très très coûteux de traitement
de l'eau en aval il vaut quand même
mieux prévenir en amont préserver la
qualité de l'eau en amont plutôt que
d'avoir à traiter avec des traitements
aussi coûteux que celui-là mais
l'exigence de la qualité de l'eau et
reste une exigence absolue et donc
j’écouterai les débats aussi des
techniciens même si ma première analyse
est plutôt une analyse négative et qui
est une fuite en avant vers plus de
technologie et vers une dépendance à
quelques groupes privés seuls capables
de porter de tels investissements
les politiques on
va pas toriales l'élection c'est le 24
septembre et vous allez nous parler
sénatorial dans le Val-de-Marne
oui tout à fait alors nous avions eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer d'ailleurs sur
cette antenne il y a quelques semaines
la gauche risque très fortement de
perdre un siège en Val-de-Marne lors des
sénatoriales de septembre suite au
municipales de 2020 sauf à réussir
l'Union face à
cette union semble toutefois impossible
à réaliser aujourd'hui les deux parties
de gauche en tête des grands électeurs à
savoir le PCF et le PS qui devrait
logiquement figurer en première et
deuxième position de cette liste d'union
souhaitant chacun présenter un homme
Pascal sabotelli pour le PCF Jonathan
kinslan pour le PS ce qui est impossible
puisque la loi prévoit une alternance
homme-femme sur les listes dans
l'hypothèse qui se rapproche de deux
listes qui se présenteraient le PS d'un
côté le PCF de l'autre et vous
solliciterez toutes les deux pour les
rejoindre ferez-vous l'union avec le PCF
ou avec le PS et si dans ce cas vous
laissez votre place à une femme
écologiste en deuxième position qui se
rappelle
alors la dernière fois que nous nous
étions vus j'avais dit je réserve ma
décision à mes à mes amis écolos donc
j'ai posé ma candidature et nous avons
une procédure qui fait que Nadine erati
et moi avons été validés par les
militants écologistes du Val-de-Marne
assez largement d'ailleurs pour être le
duo tête de liste écologiste dans le
Val-de-Marne à cessé notorial ensuite
c'est le niveau national qui décide
définitivement de des élections je les
redis moi je crois qu'il y a qu'une
bonne solution c'est une liste d'unions
et donc
et bien d'abord je vais faire en sorte
qu'il y en ait une en tous les cas je
ferai mon possible et les écologistes
feront leur possible c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'ai proposé de retirer ma
candidature pour mettre ma dîner Ratier
en deux et batailler collectivement pour
que Jonathan clemsen qui serait dans ce
cas là en numéro 3 soit élu comme Essert
Benbassa avait été lui il y a 12 ans par
une dynamique collective
à vous retirer à ne pas être candidat
pour qu'il y ait une liste du jour et
pour qu'une femme soit candidate
devant vous pour moi la dynamique
d'union est plus importante que tout
nous allons dans une période où
l'alternance risque d'être en direction
du rassemblement national et bien moi je
prône que le rassemblement de la gauche
et des écologistes et l'offre politique
nécessaire et qu'elle se construit déjà
dans les territoires et déjà au moment
des élections sénatoriales par ailleurs
la droite à conquis plusieurs villes a
gagné le département et j'espère que
nous nous mettions dans une stratégie de
reconquête et le chacun pour soi
n'aiderait pas à cette reconquête il ne
serait pas non plus dramatique les
élections sénatoriales ne mobilisent pas
non plus les foules de citoyens voilà
donc premièrement tout faire pour aller
jusqu'au bout rendre possible cette
liste d'union si elle n'est pas possible
soyez un accord national qui se discute
avec le PC et le PS je te laisse un
siège ici tu m'en laisses un ici parce
il faut que
à l'arrivée la gauche soit gagnante à
gauche et les écologistes soient
gagnants je vois bien à quel point notre
petit nombre dans au sein du Sénat est
une difficulté évidemment pour faire
entendre nos voix même si nous portons
nos voix avec convictions donc il est
possible qu'il y ait des accords
nationaux qui qui tranchent ce sujet moi
j'ai évoqué le fait par exemple que dans
les Hauts-de-Seine département voisin
s'il devait y avoir de façon certain à
socialiste élue dans le Val-de-Marne il
faudrait que une écologie élue dans les
Hauts-de-Seine ou vice-versa donc ces
discussions nationales sont logiques
dans une élection sénatoriale sinon
départementalement il n'y a aucune
raison d'aller avec les uns ou avec les
autres et si jamais au bout du compte il
n'y avait pas des unions et bien je
conduirai une liste que je chercherai la
plus rassembleuse possible dans le
Val-de-Marne avec l'espoir de passer le
cap et d'arriver malgré tout dans cette
configuration à obtenir un siège pour
les écologistes es
c'est à la Une merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous Cécile Dubois et merci
Daniel Brunier d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure
[Applaudissements]